au cours des 50 dernières années la
population mondiale a doublé les quatre
jours nous sommes un million de plus sur
la planète
c'est la plus grande crise de l'histoire
de l'humanité que les inspirer à la
fédération sa décision de ne plus
autoriser qu'un seul enfant par famille
en promulguant la loi sur le quota
d'enfants et bâtir un monde meilleur
pour nos enfants
ferez vous pour cacher sa du bruit
vous avez pensé à des prénoms fait fi
lundi mardi mercredi jeudi vendredi
samedi dimanche à partir de demain zèle
et sortir chacune votre tour le jour de
la semaine correspondant à votre
traitons tous les dimanches sera
dimanche qui sortira
adil sortira le lundi
et ainsi de suite
[Musique]
hors de ces murs
vous adopterez toute l'identité unique
de karen cette manne
[Musique]
non s'il vous plaît
karen cette manne auriez vous quelque
chose à déclarer
et non
et quoi que vous fassiez et
que vous vous trouviez il ne faudra
jamais dire à personne que vous avez
décès et qu'est ce qu'elle fout s'il est
blessé ou mort d' et si la police le
retrouve avant qu'au début le rater
il faut faire quelque chose pour elle il
faut sortir on n'a pas le choix
faites attention aux gens vous prendriez
un risque en sous-estimant les cette
manne
[Musique]
t
ensemble